Welcome back everyone it'ss Charlie
This is the way.
This will be my Full Mandalorian.
Season 3 Episode 5 Video.
There were a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and references,
so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get
all the episodes and cable for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet.
We'll just start at the beginning
of the episode, work
our way through shop by shore,
talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments,
starting with the episode title.
It was The Pirate,
which is a reference to Gordian Shard,
who makes a huge assault on Navarro
in retaliation for earlier this season
when Greek Karga and Mando killed his men.
They also imply that he's working in
concert with Moff Gideon in Thrawn,
and this is all part of their grand plan
to rally like the forces of
the Empire are slowly building again
or rebuilding in the outer rim.
The other big reason why Gordian shard
would want control of Navarro
is because now it's getting much richer,
because it's a major trade hub.
So he wants all that
money is flowing through the system.
But because of everything during
CARSEN Taylor's storyline, they imply
that something larger is at play
and he was working in concert
with the former forces of the Empire.
There's something dangerous
happening out there.
All these events.
It's not coincidence.
They keep calling them
the remnants of the empire.
You can call them the empire
however you want to think of them,
but it's basically Moff.
Gideon and Thrawn forces
the actual opening scenes on Navarro.
They feature
pretty much all the same characters
that you saw running around in the streets
during the earlier episodes.
Like, that's the same goth droid we saw
walking through the town square earlier.
Inside, Rick
Haaga is talking about more development
plans with his droids and other people.
The Droid here,
it seems like it's based on the original
Ralph McCary concept art of C-3PO,
including the other Threepio droid
he has, which seems like
it's also based on that same concept art.
You notice in the background
he's got another AR five droid.
There are a lot of droids in this episode
when Griffin Shard comes in
with his Corsair, all of his ships
and his men is there making fun of green
Karga, claiming he's gone soft as he's
tried to go legit, both making Greedo shot
first references like Han Shot
first Greedo shot first he shot first.
Well, now I will shoot first.
Yeah, I bet you have.
He also references both Sybok and Moff.
Gideon.
I think that's another callback
to Carson Teva's suspicions
that Gordon Shard is working with Moff.
Gideon forces the spin
weird patrol that he references
I believe is meant to be Carson Teva's
New Republic patrol that he works with.
When things start going crazy in
the streets and everyone starts fleeing.
This white threepio droid,
I believe is the same one from season two.
I think she was meant to be
the schoolteacher,
the lava flats
that he mentions that they go to.
We saw during season one,
which they also reference
at the end of the episode, basically
giving them in a bunch of territory
to the mandalorians
sort of a homecoming episode for them
because they used to live on.
NAVARRO Then we travel to a Delphi base,
picking up with cars and table patrol.
There's y wings.
X-Wing Basically all the standard
New Republic ships you would expect.
We visited this place
during the Mandalorian season
two Episode two as well.
He gets Greek saga's message Seems
reluctant to ask The New Republic for aid.
I think he's just bristling at the idea of
all the bureaucracy of the New Republic.
Like they want to throw
the New Republic under the bus
even more like
they did during episode three.
They make a lot of jokes
about The New Republic during the episode,
but it's all part of this storyline where
Greef Karga told Mando in episode one.
Like it's a callback
to that where he said he wanted
to keep Navarro as independent as possible
from all the different governing bodies,
the different forces in the galaxy,
primarily the New Republic,
the remnants of the Empire, the Hutt's,
any other major organization.
That's why he was so happy
to get help from the Mandalorians
because they a faction that's not looking
to absolutely control Navarro,
They're just looking for a place to live.
Had to find somewhere else to live
just because they've been living in
the Star Wars version, Jurassic Park
being eaten every other week.
Then moving back to Navarro
feels like a big step up for them.
Then we get another really cool
Easter egg.
And I actually think that it's
a bit of a set up for the Ahsoka series.
Zeb from Star Wars Rebels. He's a lizard.
They haven't returned to dispatch
in weeks.
The Swamped.
We never get an answer in time.
After the episode, I had to double check
because his voice sounded familiar.
And in the credits it is Steven Blum
and he's credited as Zed.
So this is our first big Ahsoka series
crossover that isn't just Ahsoka herself.
Like Zeb will probably be
on the Ahsoka series or a cell.
We did.
You know, we were so
I know the protocol has changed
for crying.
Ahsoka My name is Ahsoka Tano.
We'll see if his appearance
in this episode leads to something bigger
from his character.
This season, like a reunion with Ahsoka
at some point, or a reunion
with the other characters from the goes.
But do not be surprised
if we get a much bigger cameo scene
from those live action versions
of the ghost characters in Rebels.
If you didn't watch Star Wars Rebels, he
was just a member of the Crew of the Ghost
and the doing a live action version
of all those characters
from the Ghost on Ahsoka
I did an Ahsoka trailer video last year.
Pretty much all the footage of her inside
a ship was inside the Ghost.
And speaking of the Ahsoka series,
Dave Filoni directed
and he wrote all the episodes.
Dave Filoni also cameos in this episode.
Zoom in Enhance. He's
also at the bar here.
He's wearing his trademark
hat that you always see him in.
His name is Trapper Wolf.
He appeared in previous seasons.
They also brought back the other Star Wars
directors, Rick Farmer,
who directed and executive produced
some of this season in particular.
He's directed previous seasons, too.
And Deborah Chow's character,
because they played
New Republic pilots back
during season one.
So like they are saying
that they were part of this squad.
Deborah Chow also directed all the Obi-Wan
Kenobi episodes cards, and Taber
goes back to course on
to get the New Republic's formal help
with Korean chart with Colonel Tuttle,
played by Tim Meadows, who most of you
remember from Saturday Night Live.
He's been in a billion things
since then, so
you probably recognize him from somewhere.
It will happen.
And welcome to the ladies
man, The Love Land.
With all the right
responses to your romantic query.
If he's meant to be in charge
of the requisition office where
Elliot Kaine is working, paying off
her appearance during episode three,
she clocks Carson Teva and pricks up
when he rolls in asking about Navarro.
The whole idea here is that Navarro
used to be under imperial control.
They also had that secret base there
where Dr.
Pershing
was working on the cloning project,
which is a reference
to a bunch of different storylines.
The whole Grogan
cloning plot started out as the emperor,
trying to find a way to clone himself,
which is a reference
to the sequel trilogy.
There are Easter eggs for that
during the bad batch on Mount Tantas,
which is also from the heir
to the Empire storyline.
And during that there was for sensitive
cloning that there was a Luke clone,
there was a clone of a Jedi master doctor.
Purging has a lot of different ideas
about what they can do with cloning.
I know there are theories
that he himself is a clone too.
And I think part of the idea
is that some of the other Imperials
that are still in charge, like Moff
Gideon's Men, Theron's men
also want to use that cloning project
to clone force sensitive troopers.
So this is like a lot of stuff going on
in that cloning subplot in a lot of Moff
Gideon's former
forces were in that part of the outer rim,
which is one of the reasons
why Elliot Cain is so interested in it,
because she's in on this.
She's working as a plant for Moff Gideon
like she's secretly
still part of the empire.
She's working in this New Republic office
and she hears news about
what's happening near their forces,
but they want to make the Carson Teva
character feel like he is a smart person,
so he clocks her instantly.
Like,
why are you so interested in Navarro?
Oh, you used to work out there.
And he notices based on her badge
that she used to be imperial.
So he instantly puts two and two together
that, Oh, you are used to be out there.
You knew Navarro
because you worked with Moff Gideon.
You used to be part of the Empire.
So even though he doesn't realize
that she's still a double agent,
he knows to be wary of her like you are
shady as hell in the whole joke
with Tim Meadows.
Colonel Tuttle character is that he's
basically your average bureaucrat
who isn't willing to help
a nonmember planet
because Navarro hasn't signed the New
Republic charter they're talking about.
That's the charter
that all planets in the Galaxy
would have had to sign to gain access
to all the New Republic
support systems like basic supplies, basic
aid in there, kind of portraying
the New Republic bureaucracy
as being the beginning of its downfall.
Like, just as things are getting started
with the New Republic is already
leading to his own downfall, becoming
just as ineffectual as the Empire became.
Carson Teva starts
talking about the recent reports
of stormtroopers in the area.
Moff Gideon.
He directly references Moff Gideon.
He talks about tie fighters
flying in broad daylight, like, Look,
the empire is very clearly still very much
a big part of the galaxy in that area.
We should be paying attention.
It's also meant to be
another callback to earlier
this season with the tie interceptors,
the tie bombers
that blew up Boca Tan's ancestral home
on Call of Valor.
They're part of Moff
Gideon and Grand Admiral Thrawn forces
and connected to the big teaser
at the end of the episode too.
There is definitely something
more sinister at play.
Don't worry, I'll talk about that teaser
at the end of the episode in a second.
So when Carson
Teva says the pirate activity isn't
an isolated incident on Navarro, he's
saying he thinks Gawain Shard is connected
to Moff Gideon in Thrawn somehow, like
the Pirates are probably working
with the Imperials or working for them.
He references the rumor that Moff Gideon
didn't make it to trial, which we heard
in episode three, also setting up
the end of the episode too,
which is basically the crime scene
that he finds like,
Oh, this was the shuttle
that was meant to carry
Moff Gideon to that New Republic prison.
It never got there.
Bringing things back around to Elliott
Cain's true mission to be empire
Plant in the New Republic so that she can
keep tabs on what they're doing.
This also helps clarify
what was going on with Dr.
Pershing.
Why was she messing with his brain,
getting him to forget, even more stuff?
Why did she crank the dial up so high?
What was she trying to get him to forget?
The whole idea there is that she wants
to prevent him from informing on her.
So she wanted him to forget everything
that she'd been doing
the last several days.
Like all the meetings
that they have with each other
and probably even all memory of her
just to begin with,
just so that she could continue
infiltrating the New Republic.
The funny thing too, when he starts
trading barbs with Elliott Cain
like this, are arguing with each other,
getting kind of pissy
when she says she saw the light.
All I could think of was the Star Trek
episode, the very famous star Trek Next
Generation episode where Picard starts
going on about the lights out.
Oh, oh night.
I think the fact that she was trying
to prevent Tuttle
from sending New Republic
aid to Navarro is just confirmation
that Moff Gideon's forces Thrawn forces
were working with the Orient starred in.
They're trying to control
that area of space.
And when he warns Tuttle
about larger things
being at play in the outer
rim and it's going to be too late
for the New Republic to act once
they do find out what's really going on.
That's another reference to Moff.
Gideon and Thrawn rallying,
rebuilding their forces
in the huge endgame level event that
all the Mando Verge shows are building to.
They've already revealed
that Thrawn is meant to be like the Thanos
of that big crossover, but they didn't say
when that's actually going to happen.
Like this final confrontation.
It sounds like
it's still going to be a long ways off.
I believe the first big thing is
Thrawn will become a much bigger character
during the Ahsoka series
and then eventually you start
seeing him crossover to other series.
But I also think this is meant
to be a reference
partially to the season three finale
where both the Mandalorians
and the Empire, like Moff, Gideon
and Thrawn forces all have rallies like
they both go out on very high moments,
like Really Good for the Mandalorian.
It's like they all come together, unite.
But also on the other side of the coin,
the former imperial forces
like Moff Gideon, Men in Thrones
people also unite,
and it just becomes a big escalation,
pushing into future seasons in the spinoff
shows like the Ahsoka series.
I also think what they're
trying to show here with The New Republic
being so bogged down in bureaucracy
is they want to show you how it was able
to fall to the first order.
Like how was the first order
able to form under their noses?
Why weren't they watching more carefully?
Because they were so bogged down
with bureaucracy,
All the chips that they joke
about in his office lying all over
the place are also reference to episode
three with Doctor purging.
They're all meant to be the old imperial
ships like old star destroyers, Capital
ships, even old ships from the rebellion
on the rebellion side of things
that they're
all in the process of decommissioning.
So like, it's all this junk
that they're slowly destroying.
So he's more worried about the trash
pile in his backyard than he is
about the big threat in the outer rim.
Then we go back to Navarro in grief,
Karga is leading the townspeople
to the lava flats.
I'm assuming
this is in every single member of the town
because there aren't
that many people here.
Like it seems like there were more people
living in this place in person.
Tava goes to the Armor's mandalorians
for help and big surprise here too,
because you actually think he was tracking
Bo-Katan ship?
Because he looks at it,
it's like, Oh, there it is.
I found it,
but then reveals
that it was actually our five D Ford
that alerted him to their presence
because our 5d4 used to be part
of the rebellion.
Working with him,
he is meant to be the same or 5d4
from a new hope, the new canon
for his character, like the new back story
is that after he blew his motivator
to allow R2 to be purchased by a large O
and so that he could continue his mission
to find Obi-Wan Kenobi,
then the Star Wars people would just say
that R five officially joined
the rebellion and became a backup unit
in one of the rebels, X-Wings
and one of the squadrons
making it sound like he also flew
in Carson Teva's
Rebellion Squadron like.
And that's how they're old pros.
The reason why the mandalorians
keep insulting Carson Teva by calling him
blue like clear out blue
is because the New Republic flag is blue.
Legacy blue on his helmet there.
They're basically saying,
get out of here. New Republic.
The message from Greef
Karga is what convinces the Mandalorians
to help with
a big rally speech from Mando and the
heavy infantryman to convince them cards.
And Tava also conveys his suspicions
that Gordian Shard
is connected to the Empire
and they're rebuilding their forces.
You notice when Mando is petitioning
the group, he holds the Armor's
Beskar Forge hammer
and like that's part of their tradition.
Any time any of them wants to address
the group, they hold that Beskar Hammer
His whole call to action
is that they shouldn't be hiding anymore.
They should live in the light of day,
setting up them permanently,
settling on Navarro In the light of day,
like literally no longer
hiding in an underground lair.
He also tries to win them over
and is sort of
the enemy of my enemy is my friend
kind of situation.
Like, remember,
we used to live there also.
They really hate the empire.
The Empire's bad.
The Empire destroyed
our planet Mandalore Shouldn't
we help them against our common enemy?
So they also want to set up the idea
that the Mandalorians are also thinking
about the empire, marshaling their forces,
like rebuilding their forces in a way
that the New Republic is not like.
Maybe the Empire is out there somewhere.
We'll deal with them later
until it's too late.
So the whole idea now is that
the mandalorians are going to step in
like they stepped in on Navarro.
It'll be them to try and stop Moff, Gideon
and Thrawn when they eventually rally.
The other big surprise here.
But paying off the previous episode,
like paying off the whole idea
that he now owes
Mando in Bo-Katan for saving his child.
This is the way. Like they're all
cool now.
No more beef between them.
They played a little funny.
Like he buries the lead just a little bit.
You think that he's going to speak
against helping out Mando Because it
mentions Grogu.
Remember when a bunch of us died
saving Grogu during season one?
They make a couple references
to that season one episode
where all the mandalorians rolled out
to help them and surprisingly winds up
siding with him like, No, no, no,
we need to go with Mando, We need to help.
Navarro.
We need to stop living in the shadows
because this is the way
Bo-Katan leads their strike force
that gives them all these orders,
because she's been doing operations
like this, leading teams like this
her whole life, going back to the Clone
Wars,
also setting up the idea
that the armor wants her
to be the person to unite all mandalorians
like, Oh, no, you're used to doing this.
You know how it works.
You're the person to make this happen.
So you just establishing that
bo-katan is a good leader.
So the whole idea here is that
Mando attacks green shards, Corsair
getting the ships to chase
into the canyons as a distraction,
allowing Bo-Katan to drop the rest
of the mandalorians in the city
and then go start strafing the Corsair
itself.
This whole orchestrated rescue mission
from the Mandalorians
is also meant to show you
what they're all capable of.
When they all work together
on a heavily planned mission.
They'll continue doing things
like this in the future
and even in a much bigger way.
During all the fight scenes
too, you notice
that the salacious crumb Kawasaki
and lizards,
like their race, are co-occurrence
of the coyote and lizard serve
as sort of hecklers during the battle,
but they were there during episode
one, too, just yelling at everybody
that passed by them in the street
During the ground assault.
They give the heavy infantryman
another cool scene of him
using that heavy repeating blaster
just like in episode three, Season one.
A lot of this battle is meant to be
a mirror of that Season one battle,
but in daylight, with even more of them,
I believe during this scene to Green
Shard also gives us our first Danke Farik
call out in a bunch of episodes.
That's sort of the Star Wars
version of the F-bomb.
Mando said it a bunch of times
during season one.
In season two, we get another cool
fight scene with the armor personally
destroying the pirates in the tower
with their hammer.
It's meant to be a callback to that Season
one battle that she had to.
We'll see her in more battle scenes.
Eventually, we get another cool
scene of Mando in Bo-Katan
dog fighting with the fighters,
taking them out like we saw earlier
this season
and then also taking out the corpse.
They're the reason why they just went for
the engine
is because even though the Corsair
isn't that big, like it's big,
they don't have enough firepower
to actually just blow it up outright.
So which is smarter for them
to take out the engine
and then let gravity do the work
of destroying the ship, work smarter,
not harder.
It's also another cool team up
with Bo-Katan and Mando,
so I can't wait to see them actually have
a ground assault team up together too.
We haven't really seen that yet.
We've seen them fight together, but mostly
just in their ships when they're dog
fighting in exchange
for saving them from Glory and Shard.
Greef Karga offers them the land nearby.
Everything from the lava flats,
which we saw way back during season
one to Bullet Canyon.
A lot of you longtime Star Wars
fans might recognize
Bullock is meant to be an Easter egg
for Jeremy Bulloch,
who was the original Boba Fett actor
in the original trilogy.
He also passed away recently
within the context of the Star Wars
universe, though Bullet Canyon on Navarro.
Here is the canyon where they rescue
the myth role played by Horatio Sanz
during Season two, where Dr.
Pershing had his secret cloning lab.
But the major idea now
is that the Armor's group of Mandalorians
won't be hiding any more like
they still are.
That underground lair.
It still belongs to them, technically.
But they'll have regular housing.
Like they won't be hiding
in a cave anymore.
They also won't be threatened
by being eaten by giant animals.
Like they won't be on Jurassic Park
Star Wars edition anymore.
Paying off Reed
Park is offered to Mando in episode one.
Like you wanted me to move here.
You offer me some land.
Well,
we'll take some of that land. Bo-Katan.
This is the armor in their former
underground lair
from the first couple of seasons
in the armor.
Tells her about their history on Navarro,
The Forge answers, explaining
more of her own history.
Like the Armor's backstory,
this is actually a pretty big deal.
People have been asking
to get more backstory for her character
for a long time in the actress Emily
Swallow, who plays her like even
she has only learned a little bit
about the Armor's backstory
and she's playing the character.
She confirms that she also visited
the Great Forge on Mandalore
before the Great Purge,
and she's remembering it in this glorious
kind of way, The way that it used to be,
then starts talking about the myth,
the or the fact that Bo-Katan
saw the living mythos, or in how it's
meant to be a sign for a new dawn
for their people,
like a new age is beginning.
But the idea is that in order for them
to survive, like the Mandalorian culture,
to survive
all mandalorians have to reunite and
they have to retake Mandalore to do it.
So that's why she asked Bo-Katan
to remove her helmet,
because she wants Bo-Katan
to be the person
to unite all the mandalorians
she's lived in both worlds.
She's live
with different types of mandalorian groups
who believe in different ideals,
and she believes
Bo-Katan has the skills needed to actually
bring everyone together and lead them.
A lot of people wondering about what
the relationship
with Bo-Katan in the armor
is because the armor previously
seemed like she knew Bo-Katan
not just by reputation, like
she knew instantly who she was without her
taking your helmet off.
Also, the fact that the armor lived
on Mandalore before the purge implies
that she was much closer to Bo-Katan
than she lets on.
The whole idea with the watch is that they
come from the deathwatch mandalorians.
They had been exiled to the moon
Concordia nearby and they weren't allowed
to come to the planet.
Mandalore implying that the armor
just had some history that predates
what happened with their big schism
within the Mandalorians.
The Mandalorian Civil Wars
is what they call them.
Those happened before Duchess.
The team took over as ruler
from their father, so that'll happen
before the events of the Clone Wars
episodes where we saw Duchess the teen.
But one of the other big takeaways
from this scene I think is confirming that
the armor does not hate Bo-Katan.
She's actually trying to push her
in the direction that she think is best
for all their people.
And this also goes back to what
the actress
Emily Swallow talked about her character.
Like, what does she want for herself?
What is she trying to do?
Because she seems so mysterious
the way she talks about her character,
at least previously
when she was just dealing with Mando
and the Darksaber is that she wanted Mando
to become the best version of himself
that he could possibly be.
And she was trying to push him
in that direction.
And she didn't want power
just for herself.
Like she held the darksaber briefly.
But nothing she's done
has been to try and maneuver herself
to become the leader
of all these Mandalorians
the way the actress is playing
the character is that
she's just someone who's meant to follow
the true ways of ancient Mandalorians
like, what is the way?
What is the true way?
I still think at some point
we will see her without her helmet.
Like we'll learn more about her
backstory in future seasons
if we don't in future episodes
this season.
The way the actress talked about it,
we're not going to learn everything
about her character
before the end of this season.
Like they weren't going
to give everything away right up front.
The whole idea here
is that she asked Bo-Katan
to remove her helmet,
giving her an excuse to leave their group,
but mostly
because she wants her to go do that.
Technically, she could still do that
by keeping her helmet on.
But the reason for removing her helmet
is just to make it easier for Bo-Katan
to blend in with the other groups
and for them to see more common ground
when she goes to these other groups.
The other really important thing here
too, is as
Bo-Katan is leaving,
she seems kind of uncomfortable.
All the other mandalorians
watching her like,
Wait a minute, she's not wearing a helmet.
What's going on here?
The armor clearly explains to everyone
what's actually going on.
It's not meant to be mysterious.
Like, No, no, Bo-Katan is going to go
unite all mandalorians
and we are going to retake the planet.
Mandalore
So even though the other Mandalorians
probably feel kind of weird about Bo-Katan
taking her helmet off, they understand
why she's doing it.
It's not like they all shun her now
or anything.
So now Bo-Katan is going to go around
the galaxy,
winning over
the rest of the Mandalorian factions
like her Night owls are a good example.
That's going to be one of the first places
she goes.
And I think they'll pay this off
by the season three finale
when all the mandalorians will come
together on mandalore the planet.
Because she said literally,
they're going to retake Mandalore
where we see a much bigger live action
version of a scene like this in Rebels.
And they also see like all the different
Mandalorian factions
see the living mythos
or I know a lot of people are now asking,
does this mean that Bo-Katan will also
eventually get the darksaber back?
There's still a lot of questions
about that.
Technically, it still belongs to Mando,
like the Darksaber rests with him.
It's a big symbol for their people,
so it's going to continue
to be a big part of uniting
all these Mandalorian factions.
My only theory right now is that
Mando will just be a big part of helping
her unite all Mandalorian factions
with the Darksaber and Grogu
will also be a big part of that too.
Got to have Grogu talking to the myth,
the sword through the force,
getting it to chill out.
Then they end on a very ominous teaser
like You end in a very high moment
with The Mandalorian, but they balance
that out with the very ominous empire.
Teaser Carson
Teva finds a derelict Lambda Class shuttle
like the one from Return of the Jedi
that looks like
it was destroyed in a fight.
The details of the wreckage
that were recorded by
the New Republic are classified,
which I think is interesting.
And when he investigates,
he finds that it's
the New Republic prison transport
that was carrying Moff Gideon
confirming the story,
the rumor that everybody believed
that he secretly escaped
en route to the war tribunal.
Also confirming it was another rogue group
of Mandalorians who rescued Moff Gideon.
But here's
what might actually be going on.
This might be a secret ploy by Moff
Gideon, who might have left
the Beskar himself on purpose
to frame the Mandalorians.
So The New Republic could find this,
think that it was them
and it would keep the New Republic
and the mandalorians busy
so they'd be distracted long enough
for the remnants of the Empire.
Moff Gideon forces Grand Admiral
Thrawn forces to all come together
before it was too late
for them to do anything about it.
But there's also the other idea
that there are many groups of mandalorians
You also have the Maul Delorean's
from the Clone Wars, like the Mandalorians
that followed Darth Maul.
You also have the Mandalorian
Super Commandos.
Those are the ones that turned sides
and followed the Empire.
Followed the Empire.
So there are bad
groups of mandalorians out there.
Let me know in the comments
if you think it was really
just a rogue group of mandalorians
who are working with Moff Gideon
in his Empire Forces
now, or do you think this is just part
of a larger ploy by Moff Gideon
to frame the regular Mandalorians
Because the whole idea is that Beskar
metal is so precious, so valuable
to regular Mandalorians they wouldn't
leave it behind unless it were on purpose.
So obviously the next big thing
they have to reveal is where Moff
Gideon actually is.
Is he working with Mandalorians
like a rogue group of Mandalorians
that are serving the empire
or is it something different going on?
Because it definitely seems like Elliott
Cain is still working on Moff Gideon
the Empire's orders
infiltrating the New Republic,
so they'd have to still be around for her
in order to do that.
It's not like she's just doing this
by herself of her own accord,
just based on the way
they're teasing stuff out.
Like they're really pulling the taffy
with Moff Gideon here, this mystery is
they'll reveal
what's really going on with Moff Gideon
before they reveal
what's going on with Grand Admiral Thrawn.
If we get a teaser for Thrawn,
I think they'll say that to the very end.
Dave Filoni also helped
write three episodes this season.
One of those episodes
could be like an Ahsoka cameo scene
where they help set some of that stuff up.
Usually the things that Dave
Filoni winds up working on are characters
that he wound up creating or writing
himself back in the Clone Wars days.
If he spotted any other Easter eggs
or references in the episode
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
My Episode six trailer video we'll post
next in my full Episode six video
we'll post next week
after they release it.
I'll also do a couple of bonus videos
this week too.
So if you have any requests
or big questions about what's going on
with the other characters,
just write in below in the comments.
Everyone click here for that Episode
six Video I the link as soon as I post it
and click here
for all my other Mandalorian episodes.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe.
And this is the way.